Rich Eisen busy last night had Thursday
night bills in the Jets some of the
bills complaining about playing on
Thursday night oh yeah if they had one
do you think that Richie incognito
Richie incognito said that he doesn't
like Thursday night ridiculous it is
ridicu I think he used far more language
it'll work you know I didn't hear any
complaints when the Eagles went to
Carolina and won on the road in a short
week or the Rams winning on a short week
on the road and San Francisco didn't
hear any of that didn't hear the Texans
a short week went to Shaun Watson at his
first career start and had left tackles
be his tight ends because they were all
in the concussion protocol for the short
week look I also heard what Sean McMann
a said of CBS which is interesting
because the Thursday Night Football
contract is up right now there there are
there is a ton of Windows there's a ton
of football windows I mean last week
just count it out because we had the the
Browns and Vikings on NFL Network in the
earlier London window at 9:30 a.m.
Eastern 6:30 a.m. Pacific thanks for
watching by the way down I did wash it
good right I was up watching I
appreciate that so on that that week you
had a Thursday Night Football window
then you had four different windows on a
Sunday from the London game the one
o'clock Eastern the four o'clock Eastern
then the Sunday Night Football game then
the Monday Night Football game if you
want to throw in because you're talking
about football fans who have to one
would think parse out their weekend to
try and find a place to sit in front of
a television set to watch a football
game while they have kids or what have
you then you include the noon Eastern
window for college football the 3:30
window for college football the seven
o'clock window for college football the
pac-12 window of 10:00 Eastern I've lost
track how many windows I just mentioned
I just mentioned 10 football windows on
a weekend so here's Thursday Night
Football continue well I've absolutely
it continues because it's a ton of money
yeah and and I prefer to say as much as
whatever you know anyone in the in the
network television world is saying about
how there are too many windows and I do
agree with that still when it's up for
grabs who's gonna say no to that
well there's talk that maybe ESPN
doesn't renew their contract for Monday
Night Football we'll see I guess what is
so much part they it's such a large part
of their programming to not have Monday
Night Football well I don't know but
that's a billion dollars I don't run I
remember when when we were there that in
the contract with I don't know how
interesting this is to anybody who's
just wants to watch TV but in their
contract with cable subscribers that
they get to charge more money if they
have the NFL package yes they're not
yeah so I don't know how this all works
out but I know just my own personal
numbers on game day morning on Sunday
morning there we've had the best start
in the history of the show the since
2008 we've had the best numbers ever so
there's still an interest out there the
question is is how sustainable is it
Rich Eisen joining us the Rich Eisen
show will follow this one immediately on
DirecTV on in Channel 239 I appreciate
you having me on the show today Dan to
to increase the level of beefcake yeah
yeah from Julian Edelman yeah to you
look you know it was funny one time when
I years ago beefcake yes beefcake
interviewing Tom Brady for my podcast
show that that now of the show after
this one has been bore of going into any
rate I I'm interviewing Tom and I'm I'm
I honestly picked out my best suit my
best suit mmm and tie combination yeah
and then decided you know what I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go sweater
vest to underneath so I'm gonna just I'm
just gonna raise my game well and I came
to that interview looking my absolute
best and then Brady walked in and it
looked like I was wearing a burlap sack
the 2-shot toughest two shot of my what
was the toughest two shot of your career
Dan other than this current one yeah
your toughest two shot it's in my
contract to always interview somebody
who's not as good looking at is that
right yeah well who's the arbiter of
that I mean who makes that decision that
that do you make that decision I make
that decision so there are times I've
had to pass on some interviews there
yeah I don't even know how I got it'll
Minh in here he snuck through somehow
he's selling books
yeah I'm selling book yeah you know the
Andrew Luck situation not good this is
bad like somebody really screwed up here
if they raised false hopes
instead of couching this by saying this
is a tricky injury to come back from
they said he was gonna be ready opening
yeah they did do that but I think the
fan base that might be upset about not
if they do feel that they weren't given
the straight skinny I think they would
much rather they were much prefer
finding out what is the plan to make
sure that he does not get hammered in
the pocket anymore assuming that he's
gonna come back from this
he played 48 of his first 48 games and
then 22 of his next 48 yeah so but you
knew the line was bad I watched Jacobi
Bruce said who's got mobility and that
guy's running for his life I wouldn't
bring him back this year I know I think
you said that on you know right here
about a month ago
yeah so I think they're making the right
decision here of course you're gonna
start hearing tons of rumors that the
reason why they're sitting him is
because they want to trade him that that
they're gonna will have a high draft of
the same conversation
the Colts had when Peyton Manning went
down with his neck injury that okay he's
not coming back because they want to get
that top pick because Andrew Luck and at
the time RG 3 was out there that they're
gonna sit there and say maybe just maybe
new general manager get a new coach
attaching to the hip of a quarterback
that does not have that sort of mileage
or problem and the show like get ready
to hear that I don't believe that
I think that they're just gonna try and
they should build a big beautiful wall
around Andrew Luck and make Jim Irsay
pay for it that's basically what they
should do we by the way have an intern
here on the show Evans and Adam Kansas
run our subway contest here is there a
question do you have for Rich Eisen
before I let him go because I don't
think he was planned for yeah well
that's what this is all about you know I
said plan for the unexpected you have a
question here what's your what's your
question do you have one who you got for
the Super Bowl this year okay okay all
right that's good
all right I said before the season the
Patriots versus the Seahawks I'm still
I'm going to stick with it right now
okay but if I had to have a mulligan
right now I would keep the Seahawks
how about that and then you're gonna go
with my Steelers I do like the Steelers
a lot yeah
because come on board well I'll bring
well you've got you've got that defense
bawling out their plan what point do
announcers stop referring to TJ watt as
JJ's brother when do you when do you
stops playing it really yeah probably
he's not this season is what no no no
he's gonna get this the entire season
okay yeah absolutely all right and then
and then juju Smiths Schuster I know
every time I say juju Smith Schuster I
think of your wife her maiden name is
Schuster and I one of these days I'm
gonna go juju Susie Schuster II know she
gets that all the time especially since
we are Jewish as well juju is not Julie
that's not that's not no he's not at
least I don't think he is for checking
yeah check on i.t Mon get the j-team on
that I was pretty sure he was Jewish
that's no he's not a member when Harold
Reynolds was with us he thought Jacques
Peterson was black so he said he was
standing that he was looking for a guy
with an afro can I give him a a mock
headline in advance oh boy if the
Steelers playing on a Saturday
and juju Smith Shuster balls out the
headline is juju rolls on Sabbath okay
thank you very much you have that he's
Rich Eisen Verizon show coming up I'll
be here all for the next three hours on
audience Channel 239 DirecTV for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]